في سبتمبر 20 22 بدات الاحتجاجات وفي
ايران وتواصلت الى الان بطش النظامي
والقمع لم يفلحاه فكان الحل بسلسله
اعدامات بحق المتظاهرين الامر الذي اثار
سخطا وانتقادات دوليه لا تزال مستمره
في افراد يشاركون في الاحتجاجات والقضاء
على اي معارضه
الثاني لحقوق الانسان
اعتبر ان استخدام اجراءات جنائيه لمعاقبه
الشعب على ممارسه حققه الاساسيه مثل
التظاهرات او تنظيم تلك التظاهرات يرقى
الى عمليات قتل بموافقه الدوله
الاوروبيه السفير الايرانيه او القائم
باعماله لادانه تلك القعده
في نهايه هذا الاسبوع تم اعدامه شخصين مره
اخرى لمجرد مشاركتهما في الاحتجاجات
اسمهما محمد مهدي كرامي ومحمد حسيني
النظام الذي يقتل شبابه لترهيب شعبه ليس
له مستقبل
داخليا الغضب
باحكام الاعدامات حيث نقل موقع ايران
انترناشونال عن الناشط الاصلاحي والعضو
السابق في البرلمان الايراني حسين مرعشي
انتقاده للقضاء بسبب تسرعه في اعدام
المتظاهرين اكد مرعش في ان القضاء لم يسمح
للمتهمين باختيار محامي عنهم او الدفاع عن
انفسهم حتى بدورها اعزازه منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه المخاوف بعد نشر قائمه
تضم مئه وتسعه متظاهرين معرضين لخطر
الاعدام كل هذه الاذنات والمخاوف
والتظاهرات في ارجاء البلاد لم تلقى صدا
في اروقه السلطات الايرانيه بل ان المرشد
علي خامنائي اعتبر ان التعامل مع ما وصفها
باعمال الشغب يتم بطريقه عادله وان اصحاب
المطالب هم مجرد مثيره للشباب
حماده حماده
اليوم
مختلف اوروبا
في ايران يبدو انها ستكون متواصله ولا
بريقه امل في المستقبل فالغضب وانعدام
الحل يزيدان من حده الاحتجاجات والمشاكل
الاقتصاديه في قلب الاحداث هذا ما خلص
اليه تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست سنه الى
قصص واقعيه من حياه الايرانيين الذين
يرزحون تحت وطاه فشل اقتصادي وتحت قمعا
للحريات يتحدث عده ايرانيين للصحيفه عن
شكواهم من ارتفاع تكلفه الايجار في طهران
وحتى ان حلم تلاك منزل صغير وسياره ولو
كانت مستعمله اصبح بعيد الملل نقلت واشنطن
بوست عن مراقبين تاكيدهم ان الوضع
الاقتصادي المتدهور اججج للترابات وزاد
السخت بشكل اكبر منذر ربيع الماضي عندما
بدا التضخم يتزايد ونهارت العمله مقابل
الدولار مسجله ادنى مستوياتها اسيه في
ديسمبر الاهم في التقرير ان قطع السلطات
للانترنت للسيطره على انتشار الاحتجاجات
اثر سلبا على احوال الاقتصاد حيث يعتمد
عليه نسبه كبيره من المواطنين في العمل
على سبيل المثال تطبيقات سيارات الاجره
والاعمال الحره الاخرى صرخات مواطنين بحسب
واشنطن بوست لم تلقى استجابه ويبدو ان
الحل الوحيد المتاح لديهم الان هو محاوله
الاطاحه بالحكومه بعد بعد من عدم الامل في
الاصلاح